this morning we are hearing from one man
who helped more than a dozen people in
his family escape afghanistan after four
failed attempts
ahmad shah mohibi is from afghanistan
and began working with u.s troops back
in 2006 when he was just 16 years old he
later came to america leaving his family
behind and work with the justice
department
and work with the department of justice
on cases against the taliban he was
worried that the taliban would target
his family and with good reason but last
week he was able to help many of them
escape and now he's working to get
another 240 people out we recorded his
first skype reunion with his
sister-in-law once she was evacuated
from afghanistan
i left everything i left my home
i left my mother which which was very
beloved to me my mother's left here
my sister
my nephews
it's very
harmful situation did you see the
taliban
yeah we saw the taliban
we all was afraid of taliban and our
kids who were afraid alone
every night there were gunshots when we
escaped
there was a bad memory of myself that my
child lost
shoes and the way
they were
nothing to wear in his feet it's very
important that we are safe now thanks
from the u.s military for saving our
life
ahmed shah mohibi joins us now good
morning to you ahmad it must have been
wonderful to be able to see your
sister-in-law safe and sound but i know
your family had to go through several
attempts several tries to get out how
did they finally make it out of there
uh well thank you glad to be here uh
through the back channels and through
the
great uh service woman and man in the
military uh to a great friends that
contacted me and offered their help
that's was the way uh we had to go to
our own channels to get them into the
airport any of efforts the four attempts
were dead through the state department
and dod
it failed and it was
it was totally a disaster in chaos how
my family went to the airport and they
couldn't get inside
yeah i know your family had taken a
picture before they left near the abbey
abbey gate where we saw the bombing what
concerns you now most as you look at the
pictures and you hear the situation
what's going on right now
i think we're in the middle of a crisis
a humanitarian crisis our government is
to act international community needs to
act afghanistan is a crisis we need to
send more people and if i was a
commander-in-chief i'll have my navy
seals and marines and all army service
women and men on the airplane right now
going to the kabul to save
thousands of people from this
humanitarian crisis and at the same time
making sure our troops are safe so what
frightens me the most is when the
taliban took over afghanistan the first
thing they did they opened the presents
and they let people out we had thousands
of isis haqqani
chechens igors all these different uh
prisoners were detained
they are all out they are a threat and
they are radical and more extremist
extremists tall upon that did not want
peace they don't want anything else uh
we see more
tragic incidents happening if this
threat if this operation is not being
controlled or managed we need a better
strategy and we need better uh a plan of
action
you know this whole thing should have
been placed a long time ago months ago
and it's it and still we have time to
save more people we do have time because
it doesn't look like more troops are
going to be said
are going to be sent in do you think
it's possible to get everybody out that
needs to get out by the 31st
not with our current plans and under
current task force that we have if my
family with all the contacts i have
cannot get into the airport in four days
or five days and how imagine how other
people get in that's how myself and
other former and active service women
and man we started our back channel to
help get end people to the airport to
this state we have about 72 people
inside the airport none of them has been
helped by the government so we are
helping our government but there has to
be a good plan in place otherwise the
thousands of people that abigail my
family was standing there there was
five families i was helping two i was
able to speak and they're fine that they
left before the explosion the other
three are still missing so more families
will get hurt and die of dehydration
stamping and explosions if we did not
come up with a good strategy and plan i
think time is running out time is
running out and so many people are still
trying to figure it out thank you very
much for your time this morning we
really appreciate and glad that your
family is safe so far
if you would like to help refugees from
afghanistan we do have a list of
resources posted on our social media
channels for you to take a look at